It feels like it belongs to someone else
that shield represents a lot
of things to a lot of people
symbols are nothing without the
women and men that give them meaning
we need someone to inspire us again
the world's more complicated
they're never gonna stop
this world is ours
there's no going back it doesn't
have to be a war it already is
we can't lose this fight
if we do this
we're gonna do it our own way
so we're partners co-workers
not necessarily a team no
we look damn good though
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new falcon and winter soldier trailer video
marvel just dropped what they're calling the final
trailer they'll probably be a couple more promos
before the first episode drops on friday but i'll
explain what the schedule is going to be and how
this is all going to work i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes just like Wandavision so be sure
to subscribe to get everything if you're brand new
to my channel and because i will be referencing
some of the stuff that happens during Wandavision
for the continuity and the timeline just careful
for spoilers from Wandavision if you haven't
seen those episodes but i'll just start with
the trailer footage first and then talk about some
of the other things that they've revealed about
potential for season two story lines as well as
some of the other movies that they talked about
crossing over into during marvel phase four
but the new trailer footage starts with falcon
practicing with captain america shield saying
it feels like it belongs to someone else
just talking about the whole idea of old man cap
they talk about basically losing him as the symbol
of captain america so there are a couple different
groups in this trailer a couple different people
talking about the need for a symbol like you have
winter soldier's character helping train falcon
how to use the shield talking about how it means
a lot of different things to a lot of different
people then you have all these government
officials the military in the u.s talking about
how they need a symbol they need to give people
someone to believe in again because they want a
new captain america i do love the extra detail
here that they provide with this footage though
you notice that falcon down here in his louisiana
home has actually put pads around all of his
trees so that he doesn't destroy them when he's
practicing with the shield and if you couldn't
tell this is louisiana where this is happening
so obviously this is meant to be falcon's family
home that he's gone back to after the events
of avengers endgame also explain the timeline
in a second too but anthony mackie said that was
actually a big deal for him because he himself in
real life is from louisiana and that's where his
main home is where he goes back to when he's not
out busy making movies like the marvel movies or
the disney plus series the whole thing here though
is just him learning to throw the shield correctly
so that it returns back to him everybody remembers
those jokes that spider-man made during captain
america civil war where he was joking to cap about
how the shield supposedly doesn't obey the laws of
physics just because of the crazy trick shots the
cap pulls off with it probably some of the best
ones though were during avengers endgame when
he was bouncing it off of thor's hammer like he
would throw the shield then throw thor's hammer
and bounce it midair to come back to him just the
craziest trick shot you could imagine ultron also
had some pretty solid captain america jokes during
avengers age of ultron just clanning on humanity
because vibranium is such an amazing resource but
all they could think to do with it was create a
frisbee just for reference too during Wandavision
we actually find out that they value vision's body
because he's made a vibranium at a grand total of
about three billion dollars and because we just
got done watching those episodes just charting
the timeline so Wandavision takes place about
three weeks after avengers endgame and the events
of that series take place over the course of a
calendar week so the finale takes place about
a month after avengers endgame not counting the
flash forward in the post-credits scene that
probably takes place quite a bit later than that
falcon and winter soldier takes place a couple
months after avengers endgame so the events of
falcon and winter soldier take place just a little
while after the events of Wandavision so i'll
bring this up when i talk about sword and what's
going on with the us government the military
because of all this captain america weapons
plus stuff that's going on in the background
there's always some shady faction inside the us
government or some secret organization like sword
that's doing something really crazy it's no
different during falcon winter soldier it's just a
different group of people that's doing this stuff
but when the series is picking up obviously bucky
is here trying to get falcon to fully take up
the shield take up the mantle of captain america
anthony mackey talked about falcon being reluctant
to do that just because it's so complicated
because things are so crazy after avengers
endgame they kind of got into that with the
sword storyline on wandavision where tyler heyward
has basically kind of gone off the rails and they
fully militarized what used to be more of like
a shield version of nasa so you have to imagine
that that same sentiment is happening with all the
other factions of the us government the military
is just doubling down going way hardcore we have
to protect ourselves in case something like thanos
ever comes back this will also get into the flag
smashers storyline too they kind of give you some
more context for what's going on with them during
this trailer footage but you have to imagine that
when you become captain america you're also kind
of the property of the us government so there's
a lot of shady stuff going on that falcon just
isn't totally sure that he wants to associate
himself with they kind of address that with the
war machine subplot during avengers infinity war
when captain america's secret avengers come back
to the avengers base like they have that bit of
a standoff moment where thunderbolt ross tells
war machine you signed the of course you agreed
to work with us you agreed to do what we
say and you remember that falcon was firmly
team captain america during civil war so he was
totally not down with thunderbolt ross so there's
a lot of politics that come with becoming the new
captain america as you'll see during the series
i know there are also a lot of people that
are theorizing that somehow winter soldier and
falcon will both share the shield because we've
seen them both use it so much but for the most
part the series is about falcon becoming the next
captain america before avengers 5. then we see the
footage of falcon in the smithsonian giving that
speech looking at the captain america costumes
and shields from the past back from world war ii
they even have a copy of the original one and his
motorcycle from that first captain america movie
the one that he was riding during world war ii
they also have an original captain america number
one comic book that circulated during the war
him punching hitler out on the cover fun fact too
that's actually the real captain america number
one comic book and in real life the actual us
military circulated i think it was almost millions
of copies of that comic book to the troops the
military itself bought tons and tons of copies
of these captain america comics and just gave them
to all the troops that were fighting in the war
that's why the number of issues that marvel sold
during that period were so high but all these
other items here or things that he was wearing
or working on or using during that first captain
america movie i think they even have one of his
drawings here because you remember that steve
rogers little skinny steve rogers before he joined
the military and got the super soldier serum was a
cartoonist there's even a deleted scene from the
first avengers movie where he's drawing a picture
of the avengers tower just sitting at the cafe
outside i even think that iron man might have some
of his drawings just as part of his art collection
but then you have falcon speech talking about the
meaning behind the symbolism of captain america
shield in the captain america name how the person
behind that is just as important as the shield
itself then they sort of juxtaposed that with the
military official or the politician whoever this
person is giving his speech trying to introduce
the john walker u.s agent version of captain
america talking about how the united states needs
someone to inspire them again the way the captain
america did wielding thor's hammer and clocking
a giant purple space hitler will do that that'll
inspire a ton of people the whole thing with the
john walker us asian captain america is that he is
just like fully team thunderbolt ross way quicker
to kill people way less likely to question the
orders that are given to him regardless of what
those orders are whereas captain america was
more about doing what he felt like was right
rather than what he was told to do then you see
the flag smashers group meeting in what looks like
the burned down ruins of this church just talking
about how complicated the world has become after
avengers endgame even though we know these are the
flag smashers they haven't told us the actual name
of aaron kellyman's character here most of you
probably remember her as enthus nest from solo a
star wars story but whatever's going on with them
it sounds like they're being persecuted for some
reason something bad is happening to them that
becomes their big call to action like she says
they're never going to stop and later she has the
conversation with falcon where he seems like he's
trying to talk her off a ledge like please we
don't want another all-out war after avengers
endgame nobody wants another war after what
just happened and she says it already is a war
so it's not really clear what is happening to
them or what the government is trying to do
to them or where they're coming from but as
you can see it clearly looks like they have
been jacked up on a diluted form of the super
soldier serum because right when they roll into
action you see them burst through that wall to
take out the security guard but later they have
a bigger version of this convoy fight scene
that they've been putting in all the trailers
and you notice that they're just completely laying
into winter soldier who one has a vibranium arm so
already pretty powerful but he's also jacked
up on a version of the super soldier serum so
he's also super strong just like captain america
so if they're able to lay the beat down on him
like falcon has all those jokes like ah that
little girl beat your ass it means that that
little girl aaron kellyman's character is also
jacked up on a version of the super soldier serum
you also probably noticed in this fight she jumps
up super high while they're in the middle of this
fight grabs falcon's red-winged drone and smashes
it over her knee so everyone press f in the chat
to pay respects to red wing at least until falcon
gets himself another one so it's not totally clear
if the flag smashers group here was a group that
the government experimented on like they were just
a bunch of test subjects that got versions of a
deluded super soldier serum or there's something
else going on with their group but the series
itself will address sort of the aftermath of
avengers endgame and how everyone isn't doing so
hot like obviously we saw Wandavision like she
has a full-blown mental breakdown as she creates
the hex with her chaos magic there's a version
of that kind of going on with all the different
characters after avengers endgame it's just that
everybody doesn't have chaos magic the way that
wanda does then even though we only get a little
bit of baron zemo in here it just seems like based
on this footage zemo himself is not in charge of
the flag smashers but he might be trying to take
advantage of them in what they're doing the same
way that tyler heyward in sword was trying to take
advantage of what wanda was doing with the hex so
like wanda created the hex by herself she did all
this on her own she did not steal vision's body
like tyler heyward lied about but when she did
create the hex tyler heyward saw an opportunity
to juice up his version of white vision with her
chaos magic so he just took advantage of what she
was doing baron zemo's thing as he says during the
trailer is to get rid of all superheroes around
the world so he might just be taking advantage of
the chaos that's being caused by the flag smashers
really love all the fight scenes obviously this
feels very much like captain america civil war or
captain america winter soldier the action is meant
to follow and flow from a lot of the action that
you see during those movies you also only see a
little bit of sharon carter footage she obviously
is one of the other main leads of the series but
they're mostly hyping this up as falcon and winter
soldier because of the whole lethal weapon mcu
aspect of it they're kind of using her in a very
black widow type of way during the series because
a lot of the series draws on winter soldier comic
book stories and easter eggs and in those stories
black widow is featured heavily but because
natasha is dead in present-day in bucky as far as
we know hasn't met the new black widow yell into
bulova yet or she hasn't fully taken the mantle of
the black widow from natasha yet after learning of
her death they'll address that during the black
widow movie mostly in the hawkeye series later
this year because i believe yelana bolova is also
supposed to show up during the hawkeye episodes
anthony mackie also said that there would be a
lot of cameos during the series we know about
war machines cameo they didn't talk a lot about
that during the press conference but we also know
that bat rock the leaper is coming back from the
winter soldier movie anthony mackie says that he's
actually been begging kevin foggy to let him be
in the new blade movie which is supposed to start
filming later this year and sebastian stan says
that he really wants winter soldier to show up
on the moon night series which is also filming
really soon and during the press conference he
actually unintentionally got kevin feige to
confirm that oscar isaac is going to be moon
knight for the mcu the whole thing with falcon
and winter soldier season 2 is that kevin feige
said that now they are discussing ideas for season
2 storyline but we won't be able to theory craft
about what that could be until we see the season 1
episodes and a few other marvel disney plus series
so everyone get hyped if you have any big
questions about the series just post them
in the comments below you can click here for
all my other falcon and winter soldier videos
and you can click here to learn all about the
Wandavision alternate ending and deleted scenes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!